if the thames barrier were to fail when
it was needed the damage would be almost
impossible to calculate the best
estimates are found so the financial
cost of london flooding would be
somewhere between 20 billion and a
hundred billion pounds the houses of
parliament every skyscraper in the city
of london every building near the river
would be unusable for weeks the central
parts of the london underground would be
out of action for months possibly more
that's before you get to the human costs
worst case perhaps hundreds of thousands
of people who'd be forced down for their
homes
which is why this barrier is designed to
not fail to be clear that still means it
can have occasional glitches or
scheduled maintenance or even have parts
of it break entirely but if any of those
things happen it must still protect
london and there's a whole team who work
here full time to make sure that it does
we aim to move each of the 10 individual
gates
at least twice a month to exercise them
today is one of our monthly test
closures for test closures we close just
as the tide is finishing going out and
that way we can wait until the tide
turns and then we get equilibrium on
both sides of the barrier and therefore
we can reopen that avoids us having to
be closed for the full tidal cycle a
couple of months ago the barrier had a
full high tide test closure and it is
dramatic normally the gates just sit out
of the way on the bottom of the river
but when they're needed they're rotated
up into place well for the annual test
closure because we're trying to maximize
the differential of the water levels on
each side of the barrier we like to
close early in the tidal cycle to allow
that differential level to build up to a
maximum of four and a half meters on a
flood defense closure we close much
later in the total cycle because we just
want to stop the danger element of the
tide going up into central london we try
and be gentle with the river so we start
by closing the outer smaller gates and
then we slowly work across into the
middle and sometimes we'll bring the two
61 metre gates in the center of the
river up a couple of metres below the
surface before we finally bring them
into the closed position and that avoids
a reflective wave of the water that's
coming in and being stopped
being pushed back downstream so during a
flood defense closure we don't have to
stop the whole tyre going into central
london we just need to stop the part of
that tide that would over top the linear
defenses
normal spring tides are going to london
each day do not over top the embankment
walls for example but if you've got a
surge element on top of that that is
what would go over the top of the walls
in london and that's the element that we
need to stop with the barrier once we've
stopped the danger element of the tide
and got a differential we've effectively
created a reservoir upstream of the
barrier we can then over rotate the
large gates and allow a controlled flow
of water upstream into the reservoir
that we've created and again that
reduces the amount of time before we get
equilibrium on both sides of the barrier
and can reopen the barrier cannot be
allowed to fail when it's needed so each
gate can be moved by one of four
separate motors that service tunnel i
was in there are two of them a few
meters apart identical with completely
independent power and control systems
the barrier has three connections to the
uk power grid from both the north and
south of the river and if the entire
british national power grid fails which
has never happened but if it does the
barrier has three separate diesel
generators any one of which could
operate the entire thing we have a
number of modes of operation so that if
when we're using mode one operation we
have a problem with technical nature we
go to mode two problem with mode two we
go to mode three we don't necessarily
have time to sort out any technical
issues but we've got other modes of
operation that we can fall back on the
barrier has to close when we need it to
i always say that if the prime minister
was stood in the house of commons in his
wellingtons and we said sorry pm we'll
get it right next tide that would
probably be fairly career limiting so
that's the technical resilience what
about the physical construction well
these piers are made of portland cement
so they'll stand for a couple of
centuries at least the steel gates are
protected by what's called a sacrificial
anode corrosion in water like this is an
electrochemical process so if you
connect a chunk of metal that's more
easily corroded to something like the
gate that chunk of metal will take the
corrosion damage instead and you can
replace it very easily whenever you need
to so the gates will also be fine for a
century or so
what if a ship hits the barrier well
ships are designed to float relatively
speaking they're not that solid these
piers are thick concrete and each of the
main gates is 3000 tons of steel
so the ship's going to come off worse
collisions have actually happened
several times in 1997 a ship called the
sand kite hit one of the piers the only
damage to the barrier was some scratch
paint and a broken ladder but the ship
sank
the trouble was that it sank where it
hit and sat broken on top of one of the
open gates that would have blocked that
part of the barrier from closing the
contingency plan if there had been a
flood tide would have been to close all
the other gates and use the force of the
water trying to get through to blast the
red ship clear
but also
even if one gate was completely broken
somehow the barrier would still not
technically fail the margin for error
would be gone but that's why the margins
there it would still hold back enough
water to keep london safe we have a
series of forecast models and we run
what we call an ensemble forecast that
looks many tides ahead with any models
particularly forecast models you will
always get a degree of error so the
forecaster here will make an adjustment
to the forecast and that data will be
passed to the controller from which to
make a decision as to whether to close
or not
so the barrier is highly reliable and
strong
what if there's a really high tide a
storm surge that's too much for this to
cope with well the design odds of that
are one in a thousand per year not
technically failure just not being
specified high enough the barrier was
designed in 1970 for a 60-year life
which would be 2030 which must have
seemed a very long way away then the
good news is that with modern
simulations and modeling the team here
are confident that it'll last another 40
years at least but part of the reason
for that is because those 1970s
engineers built in a huge margin of
safety they didn't cut corners then and
that's given us breathing space now the
gates themselves
with inspections and remedial works will
probably be good to go until 2070 but a
lot of the supporting infrastructure the
fire systems the security systems even
the cranes on the piers
will all have to be updated in the years
to come but what if the tide went high
enough to actually over top the barrier
well those gates are built strong enough
that any water they can't hold back can
flow under into the low water on the
other side remember they close the
barrier early when the river is at its
lowest point so yes if some apocalyptic
storm comes along the barrier should
still work well enough
if this was almost anything else you
could say the redundancy was
overspecified that requirements like
this were ridiculous but with so much at
stake the thames barrier is a marvel not
just of engineering but of how you have
to build when something cannot be
allowed to fail
you